[Music]
what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time
on a monday well while she's trying to
get rich dresses just trying to get our
lunch money right
i'm here with her and don't forget that
block five is now the sponsor of lunch
money what does that mean
you can go and you can get eight point
six percent apy
in an interest bearing account jason
williams is calling me right now but i
ain't answering because i'm recording
lunch money jason so you're gonna have
to
come back later uh don't forget that you
can go to blockfight.compomp
again blockfy.com pop
what's up today is the 200th episode of
lunch money is it really
yes we've been doing this for 200 days
minus one or two here and there
but 200 total lunch moneys you can watch
i came from a young naive butterfly
to a strong and uh
excited queen you know that the
butterfly is the final
evolution before it dies okay the
butterfly turned into a queen
but anyway what do you think about our
200th episode
uh it's the one right before 201 let's
go
and thank you guys if you've been
watching all this time i know sometimes
we're annoying so thank you
50 of us is annoying all the time
last year brought skyrocketing
unemployment and a global pandemic that
battered the economy but people were
still
buying homes existing home sales in 2020
rose to the highest level in 14 years
as prices climb to a record high now
every time i see
a stat like this i'm like but is it or
is it because the dollar's been devalued
so it's like this actually has nothing
to do with the dollar being oh really no
it has to do with interest rates
oh my god if you don't so they basically
what they did was they
flooded the market with cheap capital
meaning that they made it a no-brainer
for you to borrow money because they
want to
increase the velocity of money in the
market and so they dropped interest
rates to zero percent
which meant that mortgages dropped to
historic lows if not all-time lows
and when the interest rates are so low
on the mortgages people
are not only encouraged to borrow
to go buy homes but also to refinance as
well but isn't it true that a home
today is much more expensive than a home
in 2000
yeah of course well yeah home prices are
definitely higher
uh over a long period of time because
the dollar is being developed adjusted
on an adjusted basis yeah yeah if you
account for
inflation of course but the because the
inflation is so it is a real record high
guys
yeah but well what they're talking about
so we're clear
is home prices are rising uh
the actual price but it's because
there's a fixed supply or a relatively
fixed supply
of real estate it's hard to build new
real estate um
and especially if also you're shutting
down construction for part of the year
because of coronavirus all that
and if more and more people want to buy
homes and there's cheap capital
available to go buy those homes
plus you get that all uh kind of
combined with the fact that people were
leaving cities looking to move elsewhere
all of those trends just meant like
increasing demand
supply stays pretty constant so prices
have to go up to accommodate everybody
especially bitcoin speaking of bitcoin
this unknown maryland-based lottery
winner who won
731 million dollars in the powerball
jim cramer has a message for her he says
he says you know what if you won the
lottery yes i'm gonna say it
five percent in bitcoin so he is
recommending
the lottery winner alec five percent of
his or her
newfound fortune in bitcoin what do we
think so
kind of that's what he said i watched
the actual video because people send it
to me
um what he basically said it he threw it
in as kind of a throwaway comment at the
end
i don't think he was saying like this is
the first thing you should go do
he also cap yeah i just yawned man they
just they just sneak up on me sometimes
they just get me only when i'm on this
show
y'all on the rest of the day what are
you saying on this channel the show is
boring because we've had 200
successful watched episodes no i'm
saying that i'm very relaxed on the show
you know i just chill as as jim cramer
calls himself
jimmy jimmy chills this is pop chill
right now
uh but five percent is he basically said
it in a way of like look if you're gonna
go
and you're gonna really kind of have a
high risk bucket uh five percent bitcoin
like fine do it
um so look it's cool like super excited
that jim cramer is in
uh to bitcoin he bought some bitcoin i
know for a fact because after i
interviewed him
he literally wouldn't let me get off the
call until he went and bought the
bitcoin
um and so he's just like i think a good
dude that a lot of people listen to
especially the older generation so
having him out there
explaining bitcoin and teaching people
about it isn't that possible do you
think the lottery winner should allocate
some of their winnings to bitcoin
if i won the lottery i would take
majority of it all of it
yeah i mean it's found money right like
you
you just came into this windfall of
money the number one thing the lottery
winner should do is invest it rather
than try to go spend it
or yeah or just buy 700 million dollars
and uh you're not used to managing money
the things you try to go buy are like
cars and houses you probably don't even
buy a yacht or
houses and yeah i buy a jet oh my god
okay to fly everyone all right i watch
this lunch money to come hang out with
me oh
lunch money live um god
okay so you know michael saylor
microstrategy heard about him before he
bought
another 314 bitcoin for 10 million
on friday what he is just buying away
well so hold on michael saylor's put
over a billion dollars into bitcoin
and uh he now holds 70
784 bitcoin
savage absolute savage uh look he uses
the treasury reserve for
uh micro strategy um and then he also
holds about
uh a quarter of a billion dollars
himself personally so
whenever he gets more money from the
company meaning that there's revenue for
the business he's going to keep buying
more now he just
so happened to buy it when it dropped um
and so he kind of bought the dip
uh my favorite thing i saw online was
the guy owned 70 000
uh bitcoin and then was like ah i need
an extra 300
but i think that he's going to keep
doing this because he's literally
as he gets dollars from the revenue of
the business he's going to keep
converting it to bitcoin so it shouldn't
be surprising funny and interesting
um so gamestop is squeezing the short
sellers
tell us about it this is my favorite
story
it's so so much his favorite story on
friday night or saturday or
what day are we today i think saturday
he was making me watch these like
cat person videos boring kitty roaring
kitty videos about
game stock and i was watching this man
with the cat shirt
on go through his excel chart and show
me his portfolio
well hold on so for those that haven't
been paying attention game stock uh
shares are up a ton they used to trade
under a dollar
they used to trade under a dollar then
they were hanging around five dollars
now they're trading i think it's at like
65 bucks or something 70 bucks and the
reason why this happened
was wall street bets and a bunch of
what i'll call degenerate day traders
and i mean that in the most loving way
possible like i think they're hysterical
these folks all said look there's so
much short interest
in game stock stock but they are game
stop
stock game stop stock uh that they are
mis
they are misinformed like this is
actually a good stock and so what they
did is they all went and bought the
stock at around the same time
and it created a short squeeze and so
all of a sudden all the short sellers
had to start buying up stock to kind of
cover their positions
which only drove the price higher and so
the stock literally went from like five
or six bucks to over sixty dollars
uh in a very short period of time and so
uh there's this
guy who is kind of the leader uh or one
of the leaders in wall street bets
around
uh game stop and uh he
now owns eight figures over 10 million
dollars worth of
game stop stock uh and he's been
basically talking about this for like 18
months roaring kitty on youtube that's
his name
i think it's roaring kitty uh but
absolutely fascinating story the short
sellers
uh what was it
i don't know all the details but he
turned a little bit of money into a lot
of bit of money like 50k
like 10 million dollars 11 million um
but the the best part of the whole thing
is uh reddit and the memers on the
internet
are teaching wall street don't play here
you ain't want to mess with us
because they literally just created a
short squeeze uh
that enriched all these you know roaring
kitties
on the internet and uh there's
professional sellers that were short
that they got wrecked next topic
tom brady is headed to his 10th
super bowl not under the patriots
name though he is wearing a buccaneers
jersey
you see me knowing the sports
tom brady's the second best quarterback
in history
who's the first eli manning
from the new york jets or new york
giants the hell
yeah i was thinking jets because the
jets
the best team in new york is the new
york giants uh no do you want to know
why
because they met in the super bowl twice
and eli manning beat them both times
okay
tom brady's over has he been to 10 super
bowls and does he have that many
rings well if you've gone to 10 super
bowls if you've gone to 10 super bowls
and you haven't won them all then
are you really the greatest yes because
he's got all the
rings and eli manning beat him twice
tom brady doesn't want to see eli
manning in the super bowl if tom brady
sees eli manning in the super bowl
you know who's winning and it ain't tom
brady just saying
are you lying is not even relevant what
are you talking about
he's two super bowl rigs and he went
right through
tom brady together let me let me talk
about it last night he was saying he was
the goat
yeah tom brady is he's very good but eli
manning is the goat
no not what you said okay so uh if you
follow the profile or
me on twitter you will have seen that i
tweeted the most
fire tom brady quote in the history of
tom brady quotes
somebody uh he goes he goes you want to
know which
ring is my favorite the next one
that is good i just love that it's like
the the win
the joy of winning is in the pursuit of
winning
that is a great quote uh and tom brady
is very very
does eli manning have rival rival quote
time
you want to know what he has yeah you
want to know which one was my
my favorite super bowl the one where i
beat tom brady
only you think that's funny no patriots
the patriots were great it was awesome
but the only team
that they know that they can't talk
about the giants have been to
your giants yeah they were
undefeated against tom brady in the
super bowl
have the giants really only went to the
super bowl twice no they've been
multiple times other than that but i'm
just saying that in recent memory
in recent history when tom brady the
goat the guy who was so good at football
met the stoic
rocket arm maybe a spaghetti arm but
rocket
arm of eli manning in the super bowl
i can't even talk one warrior left the
arena
twice with a ring and it wasn't our
friend tom brady
i can't even talk about this because i
have to pretend to care but i
genuinely don't care or understand so
i'm just
a opinion of opining on things that
i literally couldn't when somebody asked
you okay how good is tom brady just say
oh sorry i can't remember because eli
manning beat him twice i like giselle
what's up my girl okay
um ask lunch money time 200th episode
edition
ask lm in the comments oh my god
somebody asked who the best quarterback
in the nfl was
eli manning
do you think that could be a good
quarterback they don't really get
tackled and they don't really run right
no but they have to actually you have to
throw the ball i can do that
have you seen bait bait just go just go
jessica you also have to know the plays
go ahead
what's a plays oh like the play yeah
you're gonna
you're gonna be a great quarterback yup
come on ask the question god
stupid country and it's stupid sports
all right um so what are we today
so okay ask lunch money time your
questions below hashtag ask
mlm wow marco luccicini oh i like that
name marco luccini
when you write an article how do you
structure your idea especially if the
argument is complicated
well for me i have
for first um so i write my articles like
a puzzle like sometimes i'll start at
the
end and go to the top or sometimes i'll
start in the middle and then like what
do i want for my head
like i don't write an order but then
after your first draft it might be super
long and super complicated
and then you start cutting and slashing
and deleting
until it's clear send it to your mom if
she can understand it then you've done a
good job
go on i live with a psychopath
who starts writing at the end sometimes
you know what you
want your ending to be and you don't
know how you want to start it
who starts in the middle i do psycho
it's like a puzzle
it is not like a pause i sit down like a
normal human
and i start at the beginning and then i
write the middle and then i write the
end
like a normal person you know just like
how when you write about complicated
topics how do you
structure them i don't i don't do any
pre-structuring i don't do any outlines
i don't do any of that i literally
sit down and i pretend like i'm talking
to somebody and how i would explain it
and that's how i explain things is i
start at the beginning
shocking idea uh and then i do the
middle and then i do the end
i don't start at the end like imagine if
somebody asked you a question
and they were like explain inflation and
then you just jumped right to the middle
and you were like so let me explain
interest rates
no but that's not how you answer that's
how you write i don't
okay how i think i think i know i write
how i think
rachel green unless it's your real name
i see what you did there that was very
clever
what you don't get it what rachel green
was in friends
the name of jennifer aniston and friends
ask ellen
but if you could it could be your real
was it spelled r-a-y-c-h-e-l-l
it was not but i like this spelling
better rachelle i think
they pronounce it uh-oh is it rachel or
rachelle guys
i've never seen rachel spelled r-a-y-c
okay you've never seen paulina spelled
p-o-l-i-n-a but yeah
yes i have no i literally have my wife
just spelled that one
the regular spelling is p-a-u-l-i-n for
those of you for the trolls who try to
be mean to me and
misspell my name at least spell the name
right okay
what are rachel or rachelle asks
what are your long-term financial goals
what are yours
financial
i want to have the most fiat
money in the world because if i have all
the fiat money then i can
i can put some in bitcoin but you don't
let me invest in bitcoin so
what can i do i'm not going to comment
on this
uh question i will have more for you
soon
oh wait is it what i'm thinking it is
okay yeah
it's a good one guys it's a good one
okay soon maybe in february i will
answer this question
i have a very good answer but i don't
want to spoil it his answer is to be
happy and that translates to his
financial goals too
true okay but i ha but i i have an
announcement
we have an announcement well i'm gonna
make you
make the announcement why because
you start at the end and then right the
middle and then go to the beginning
it's not that serious but you go and
like it okay all right
that's it that's it dot com happy 200th
episode please tweet to plan ah meme and
make her and make her laugh today
see you wait tweet up tweet bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends